but back
to librex so what uh what's the founding
story what's the founding principles of
librex
sure so i was on campus as a freshman
and i was talking to my friends many of
them
felt like it was hard to raise your hand
in class to ask question
they really felt like even outside the
classroom it was hard to be vulnerable
and the thing you have to understand
about yale is it's not that big a place
everyone knows someone who knows someone
who knows you basically
yeah um and people come to these schools
first of all they're home for people and
they want to be themselves they want to
feel like they can be authentic they
want to make real friendships
and second of all it's a place where
people go for intellectual vitality to
explore important ideas and to grow as
thinkers
and fortunately to the culture my
friends expressed that
it was very difficult to do that and i
felt it too and then
i couldn't talk to my professors and i
remember talked to one specific global
affairs professor
and i was taking his class and his area
of expertise was in the middle eastern
conflict
and i went to him and i said professor
we've we're almost finished this class
and we haven't even gotten to sort of
the reason i originally wanted to take
the class was to hear about your
perspective on the middle eastern
conflict because something i'd learned
at yale and this is
maybe a sort of a tangent but i'll i'll
flush it out a bit
something i learned at yale is that you
can learn all sorts of things from a
textbook
and what you kind of go to yell to do is
to get like the opinions of the experts
that go beyond the textbook and to have
those more in-depth conversations
and so that's sort of the added value of
going to a place like yale and taking a
course there as opposed to
just reading a textbook but also
interact with that opinion exact
person yeah to interact with that with
that opinion to hear it
to respond to it to push back on it and
to have that
with some great minds and there really
are great minds at yale don't get me
wrong it's a
place it's still a place of tremendous
brilliance
um so i'm talking this professor right
and i'm like we haven't
i haven't heard your area of expertise
and i'm like are we going to get to it
what's the deal and he this is during
office hours mind you so we're one on
one
it says ryan to be honest i used to
teach this area
every single year in fact i would do a
section on it which is like a
small seminar like breakaway from the
class where he would
talk to the students in small groups and
explain his
and explain his perspective his research
and have a real debate about it
like around a harkness table and
he said i used to do this and then about
two years ago a student
reported me to the school and
i realized my job was at risk and i
realized the best course of action was
basically
just not to broach the topic um
and so now i just don't even mention it
and he's like you can say whatever you
want but
i'm not i'm not gonna be a part of it
and it's a real shame it's a real loss
to
all of the students who i think
came to the school to learn from these
brilliant professors
in that context of these world experts
the problem seems to be that reporting
mechanism
where there's a disproportionate power
to a complaint
of a young student a complaint that an
idea
is painful or an idea is disrespectful
to you know or
ideas creating an unsafe space
and uh the the conclusion of that i mean
i'm not sure what to do with that
because it's a single reporting maybe a
couple
but that has more power than the idea
itself
and that's strange i i don't know how to
fix that in the uh
administration except to fire everybody
so like this is to push back against
this storyline
that academia somehow fundamentally
broken i think we have to separate a lot
of things out
like one is you have to look at faculty
and you have to look at
administration and like at mit for
example
the administration does
tries to do well but they're the ones
that often lack
courage they're often the ones who are
the source of the problem
when people criticize academia and i'll
just speak to my s
to myself you know i'm willing to take
heat for this
is they really are criticizing the
administration
not the faculty because the faculty
often times
are the most brilliant the the boldest
thinkers that you think whenever you
talk about we need like the truth to be
spoken the faculty are often the ones
who are in the possession of the deepest
truths in their mind
in that sense and they also have the
capacity to truly educate the way that
you're
you're saying and so it's not broken
like fundamentally but there's stuff
that like needs
that's not working that well and you
kind of you kind of took my words that's
what
that's what i thought you were going to
ask me if i think the ivy league is
broken that's
totally that's exactly it so you don't
think yeah so on the question do you
think the ivy league is broken
like what how do you think about it uh
the academia in general i suppose but
ivy league
still i think it represents some of the
best qualities of academia
yeah what more is there to say there i
think the ivy league is producing
tremendous thinkers to this day
i think the culture has a lot that can
be improved
but i have a lot of faith in the people
who are in these institutions
i think like you said the administration
and i have to be a little careful
because
um you know i've been in some of these
committees um and i i have
talked to the administration about these
sorts of things um i think they have a
lot of stakeholders
and unfortunately it makes it difficult
for them to always
serve these brilliant faculty and the
students in the way that they would
probably like to
yeah okay so this is me speaking right
the administration
i know the people and they're oftentimes
the faculty holding positions in these
committees right
yes but it's in in the role of quote
unquote service
they uh they're trying to do well
they're trying to do good
but i think you could say the mechanism
is not working but i could also say
my personal opinion is
uh they lack courage
and one courage and two
grace when they walk through the fire
so courage is stepping into the fire
and grace when you walk through the fire
is like maintaining that like
like as opposed to being rude
and insensitive to the lived
quote-unquote experience of others or
like
you know just not eloquent at all like
as you step
in and take the courageous step of
talking and saying the difficult thing
doing it well like doing it skillfully
so both of those are important the
courage
and the skill to communicate difficult
ideas and they often lack them because
they weren't
trained for it i think so you can blame
the mechanisms that don't
that allow 19 20 year old students to
have
more power than the entire faculty or
you could just say that the faculty need
to step up and grow some guts and and
skill
of graceful communication really
administration
well yeah and the administration that's
right that's the administration
the faculty are sometimes some of the
most brave outspoken people
yes within the balance of their career
you